the way I built a community by spending
the last 17 years making content that
actually brought value to people instead
of bringing value to me my friends who
know that I came from little and I live
the life now they want me to post
something bougie they want me to post a
watch they want me to post a car they
want me to post a plane they're like why
don't you do that I'm like because it
brings no value to anyone what the [__]
does that do for you nothing most people
want a front most people want to project
something if everyone here talked about
their true skills their true passions or
their true challenges they'd be able to
be a community Builder everybody here
has massive value to bring to the world
most people are not willing to be
vulnerable enough or honest enough or
authentic enough to be able to get it
out of them you've got to build content
that matters nothing else matters